-Our first guest tonight hosts
"Deadline: White House" weekdays
from 4:00 to 6:00 p.m. on MSNBC.
Please welcome back to the show
Nicolle Wallace.
Nicolle, how are you?
-I'm good.
I have to say, I was on TV
for most of it
and hadn't processed it
until I heard your summation,
and I couldn't have said it
better myself.
I mean, that is
exactly where we are.
That's exactly
what happened today.
-I want to thank you
for the fact that you were on TV
very late last night,
covering the Georgia runoffs,
and then, of course, you were
kept on camera all day today,
as you mentioned.
So thank you so much
for finding time for us as well.
Are you exhausted?
-No. I mean, look,
there are people
who have so much more at risk.
And I'm just ruminating on
what you said about
what has to happen to the people
who supported
today's insurrection
in Congress
and the sedition caucus
that were carrying out
a fake thing.
There is no legislative vehicle
for overthrowing
the results of an election
that was fair,
that was verified,
that was counted and recounted,
that was litigated in 60 court
cases across the country
from coast to coast by judges
from both political parties.
So the only thing I would add to
this group of people,
starting with Donald Trump
but also the 12 Republican
Senators
and more than 100 House members
and all of the supporters of
Donald Trump's
who were at the Capitol today,
endangering the lives of
everybody inside --
staffers, members of Congress,
senators, the police officers --
we have to make sure that people
who are on the other side of
democracy get voted out as well.
I mean, Donald Trump
should be removed
because he is,
right now at this hour,
a national security threat.
And I worked in a White House
where we dealt with
national security threats
in a very different way
than they're being dealt with
right now.
But that's what Donald Trump is.
He's a clear and present danger
to the country
he ostensibly leads.
But even that is unclear
at this hour.
It was reported that Mike Pence
was the one that authorized
the National Guard coming in
to aid Capitol police.
-You mentioned your time
in the White House,
and you were obviously working
in the White House during 9/11.
And you've mentioned today
to some of your guests
that you had a flashback to that
because it must have been
terrifying for those
that were in both chambers
when this was going down.
-Yeah. Well, Congresswoman
Linda Sanchez came on the air
and said that last night she
called her husband in California
and told him where he could find
her will.
So last night Congresswoman
Linda Sanchez thought
it was possible that today
she would die at work.
She works in the Capitol.
So it is inexplicable to me
if she thought yesterday
enough concern that she told
her husband where her will was,
and she has an 11-year-old son,
she got very emotional
telling me this story,
why didn't the Capitol police
have a better plan
than they had?
I mean, it didn't appear that
the protesters, the rioters,
met any resistance at all.
And to me where
this was similar to 9/11
was that both chambers
were evacuated.
Members went to
undisclosed locations
and they sheltered in place.
What was different
was the response.
I mean, after 9/11, many of
the things that this country did
in the name of making sure that
terrorists never flew airplanes
into the World Trade Center
or the Pentagon
or crashed in Pennsylvania
will be polarizing decisions.
But everything changed.
Today the Republicans went back
to the floor of the Senate
and six Senators still sought
to overturn the results
of the election,
still sought to delegitimize
Joe Biden's win.
So what's disturbing to me
is more the ways that it was
different from 9/11,
that we didn't wake up from
this sort of drunken stupor
of disinformation
and lies and smears
that endanger, at this point,
all of us.
-Yeah. There was a moment that I
think was also very clear-eyed
where, you know, Mitt Romney
took the floor
and basically said we have to
tell these people the truth
because when we lie to them,
they're very upset by reality.
And yet as you mentioned, people
came back into the chamber
and, you know,
ostensibly this is about
"Hey, we want evidence.
We can't move forward
unless there's evidence."
And yet if you listen to some
members of the House tonight,
if you watch
right-wing cable news,
the speed at which they're
saying this was actually Antifa,
now, obviously, that is a claim
that cannot this soon after what
we just saw be made
with any evidence.
And so that I think is
the most terrifying thing,
is how quickly, as you point
out, it went back to normal.
-And it suggests that
we're just in the --
you know, we're in grooves now.
And I think --
you know, I thought this a lot
as we floundered and failed to
contain and protect one another
from COVID, that if Donald Trump
were the president
and the disinformation
were in place,
you could see people refusing
to abide by TSA requirements
and say, "I'm not taking off
my shoes
or throwing away
my Fiji water bottle.
It cost me $4."
We are not the same country that
we were on September 11, 2001.
We are not represented by
the same kinds of leaders.
There is -- Clearly after today
there is nothing
that jolts them out of their --
and it's not partisanship.
This isn't in the name
of the Republican Party.
This is in the name of
a cult leader, Donald Trump.
-You know, we're often told
that, you know,
senators like Josh Hawley,
like Ted Cruz,
these are brilliant lawyers.
You know,
Donald Trump's one thing,
but these are intelligent men.
These are serious men.
And yet when you watch
what they did today,
were you surprised
or is this in line with
their behavior in the Trump era?
-You know, I thought on election
day that Trump was like
a popped balloon, that he was no
longer the most newsworthy part
of this really terrible moment
in our politics.
And I instantly started covering
much more aggressively
the Republican enablers because
I thought if, after the election
was lost by Donald Trump,
if all the Republicans,
if Mitch McConnell and Kevin
McCarthy and all the Republicans
came out and said,
"Hey, we voted for you, Donald,"
because we know he's a big baby,
they had to make clear
that they were there for him,
"but the country went
a different direction,
better luck next time,"
that none of this
would have happened.
And I believe that about today.
So with that stipulated,
I actually think
the more egregious offenders
to our democracy,
the people putting all of us in
danger and capable of doing so
after January 20th are
the Josh Hawleys of the world.
And if one more person says on
our air how well-educated he is,
he may be well-educated
but he's clearly not smart.
Or if he's smart he doesn't care
about the country he lives in
or the fact that
it's a democracy.
-I think it's really important
to stress that
our nation's best universities
are filled with
some real dummies.
And that has always
been the way.
-And conversely
our public universities
turn out some good folks.
-Yes, absolutely.
It's a mistake to think
what's on the diploma
speaks certainly to
the character of a person.
You know, I feel as though
people like myself maybe
have been framed as being
overreactive or hysterical
when we point out, you know,
how awful it is to say,
after Charlottesville, you know,
there are good people
on both sides or to say,
during a debate, you know,
Proud Boys, you know,
"Stand back but stand by"
or, you know,
to use the word "coup."
This always seemed like
these were the cards
that Donald Trump
was showing us.
And it always seemed
as though -- and you hoped,
obviously, you were wrong,
but it did seem like
it was heading toward
something like this.
-Look, I think the lookback
on all of us
will be that
we weren't harsh enough.
Why did it take us --
It took us a couple years.
And I was one of
the first to stop
airing Sarah Huckabee Sanders,
but I wasn't fast enough.
I always called Donald Trump
a liar and a racist
and a misogynist,
but I didn't do it early enough.
I wish I'd done it
before the election in 2016.
And so I think part of what the
mob mentality on the Trump side
has done is
successfully bully people.
They call it
Trump derangement syndrome.
"Oh, you don't understand
the other half of the country."
It's not about understanding
the other half of the country.
I think that you and a lot of
people that had worked in
government before watched him,
and he wasn't doing anything
in the spirit of the state.
He never saw the country
as attached to him
or as something
he was responsible for.
He always saw it
as a possession of his.
Like, you know, he talks
about women as objects.
He talks about --
He talks about people
and the United States government
and the United States military
and his hotels the very same way
because to him
they are all objects
that he possesses and controls.
And so I think that the lookback
will be that we were not
hard enough on him, we were not
aggressive enough as journalists
in covering him and we did not
draw people's attention
to the grave threat that we now
face from him right now today
in his remaining days
as our country's only president.
We only have one at a time.
And last time I checked my phone
unfortunately he's still it.
-We're going to be right back
after this
with more from Nicolle Wallace.